what's going on guys
what's going on guys so uh as you can
see things are a little bit different
obs is having issues right now um so
i'm go ahead and i'm gonna go ahead and
start in the podcasting scene
because i don't want obs to crash again
and not let me switch options so i'll be
in the
actual scene to start the actual podcast
itself i definitely apologize uh we'll
be getting here started soon
so
what's going on guys so like i said
earlier
you're gonna have to
[Music]
bear with me
on the whole
exactly how everything looks right now
i i don't know what happened with uh obs
but it was definitely uh it was
definitely tripping
so let me uh make sure you guys can hear
me fine waiting for forte he's going to
be a couple minutes late like usual
but it's it's definitely going to be an
interesting show from what everything's
going on
that's for sure
it's definitely going to be an
interesting show
yeah and i don't know i have no clue
what was going on like every time i
would use obs
i appreciate it
uh lady firefox
every time i would use obs this screen
would freeze on obs
so it was
it was kind of a a complicated scenario
that
i wasn't really expecting
it's never done that before and it and
i've done it twice so i just reset the
pc
so far it hasn't done it
again but i wouldn't hold it past it to
do it again
so we're going to be talking about xbox
the xbox game pass somehow is hurting uh
outriders uh the the sales of outriders
are meeting expectations
uh we're going to talk about a new
playstation exclusive that looks like
might be coming into tuition i don't
know exactly 100 on that one
and the phil spencer interview that went
on
at the end of last week we didn't really
get a talk about it too much
on um
on the the iron lords podcast so i
definitely wanted to bring it up on here
it's definitely a lot more weird that i
can't rely on that starting soon screen
until everything happens man but
everything happens obviously as you can
see here
doing this by myself again just like
last week for the most part
now i don't know man it's it's uh
it's getting rough man it's getting
rough in these streets
so what what are you guys playing that's
that that's the curiosity i have right
now what are you guys playing
anything good
i've been playing a lot of hades hey
this is a great game man it's a great
game
we might talk about it a little bit
briefly on the podcast when he gets here
yeah we're definitely gonna be talking
about that
out of uh
this now let me go ahead and put up this
poll
we gotta wait for
for gaming forte because he taking
forever
but we could just chill here and talk
about some games until he gets in here
i definitely have to put in the
description
when the podcast started started
so there's that poll going out i'll let
you guys answer that
let you answer that until he shows up
gotta keep the show going man
gotta keep the show going
i don't even know why i asked man
because to me
i already know what the what topic you
guys are choosing you're choosing that
spicy topic that xbox game pass hurt
outright or sells i don't blame you
we gotta talk about it because
a lot of things about that don't make
sense to me
it just does not make sense to me
so uh
look when it comes to the
the hades we'll talk about that briefly
while i wait for him
i i'm really feeling hades man i i don't
i haven't enjoyed the game this much in
a while
but i've also been playing a lot of
skyrid sword
as you can see i was streaming that on
my actual channel so
shout out to uh the personal plug man
definitely go subscribe to the gaming
addict channel because uh you know
i've been putting a lot of content on
there here recently
got to get that took care of man gotta
put the content out
uh skyrocket sword i do think that we
was a little bit hard on that i think
there's a lot of things skyrocket sword
has going for it and the biggest thing
they don't have going forward is that
motion control but
uh do you feel like we'll be able to
attack uh a game entire on its entirety
off of one aspect i think if that aspect
bad enough most definitely like
because skyridge sword that motion
control is just horrible
it is horrible
i dropped my phone and it's probably
gonna crack
because uh
my date couldn't my day is definitely
it could definitely get worse
operating on not a lot of sleep either
so let's see what people say
yo haiti's is your 22 game of the year
just say it
um
[Music]
i don't know if it's my game of the year
but it's definitely one of the favorite
games i i've been playing
i haven't heard anything about mmos
coming to xbox no not particularly
besides final fantasy 14
uh isn't coming and it is coming they've
changed that statement a couple times
still dreaming
uh probably the same logic when talking
about piracy every download is a miss
sell
i get that i definitely get that we'll
get to we'll we'll we'll get into that
when
you know everything happens
when uh forte gets here man
we'll get to that when forte gets here
seems like obs isn't messing up again
seems like so far so good
all right let's see here
so far so good man waiting for forte to
come in here for the people that's
showing up
uh you know we we uh we're going to be
talking there's a lot to talk about
today man forte needs to hurry up i told
him 5 p.m
and he's here at 5 10.
how do i tell you something a day early
and you still late
let me add him and see if he's in there
no he's not
final fantasy is waiting for to drop on
xbox once the six months exclusivity
ends are we sure that that's happening
like are we
positive
that that game is going to be on the
xbox platform
because at this point i don't know
i don't know man i don't know if it's
going to be on the xbox platform i hope
so
i think we can all agree that you know
final fantasy definitely
needs to be
on the xbox platform i just don't know
if microsoft bought that full-time
exclusivity or not
that's the question
i don't think they would care if it went
to pc but i think they're trying to keep
it off of xbox at all cost
they can keep godfall i'm good on
golfball
i don't need golf all my life to feel
accomplished
uh why do game pass conversation mostly
end badly what exactly do you mean by
why do game pass conversations like are
you talking about like
in terms of if they sell well or
something like what exactly do you mean
ps direct going live in five minutes
there's a direct today
i didn't know that
where is the direct sir
i'm still waiting for final fantasy to
come to a game pass as promised
if it does come to xbox i wouldn't be
surprised if um
xbox makes sure that's on game pass day
and
date because to me if if you miss on a
launch day window it's still not all
right
but it does help it a little bit if it
comes into
the the xbox ecosystem and game pass if
it did miss the window the initial
launch window
why do gamers worry about money and
who's getting paid i think that mainly
just comes from
the health of the company itself like
you do have to worry about
exactly how a game sells and you know
the the semantics behind all that
because if the game doesn't do well or
the company doesn't do well then clearly
they're not going to invest more into
the company
and uh though eventually close down that
section
so i think that's why people you know
talk about cells to a point but i do
agree with you that you know we're a
little bit too much when it comes to
talking about the cells in general
i don't think we should be talking about
sales as much as we do but they do need
to be talked about
and keep in mind you guys like we
we're content creators we
we
gossip about the
the gaming industry we talk about the
gaming industry
uh
pretty much
that's a lot of people's jobs here so
that is a really relevant conversation
that i don't blame certain youtubers for
having that conversation
outright it still has not left game pass
yet no i don't think it has
i
uninstalled that after i had the
the mad issues that i had with the game
it's definitely uh they need to
i felt like their priorities when that
game was broken was messed up
that's just my opinion though
yeah that's that's what i'm saying uh
gomez like the game was just a mess
complete mess at launch and i don't
understand why
people assume that
well we're not gonna talk about i'm not
gonna get too much into it still gotta
wait for forte
we're not gonna talk too much into it
man
just keep the
podcast talking smoothly we don't need
to talk about the topics in the pre-show
because this shouldn't be a pre-show but
i gotta wait for forte so i guess it is
a pre-show
that's too much
that's good
uh
so what um
obviously you see the the new
playstation exclusive rumor what
playstation game would you guys want to
come back i'm curious
tell me in that in that comment section
man or you know if you're definitely if
you're still here in the live chat tell
me what you guys want to be uh played on
there
what game
i couldn't really tell you to be honest
on my end i guess maybe it's just
because i've never really
you know played
i think jack and dexter would be my
choice actually now that you make it
mention it mike fury
i would definitely love
a
jack and dexter game
what is eminem
i'm unaware of that game
a jumping flash i've never heard of
jumping flash silent hill would be a
good thing i don't think they would
bring back infamous it's not old enough
dragoon
i could see that that would be a good
game
i could totally see
uh they brought back him uh uh
omoshu or however you guys want to
pronounce it you guys know i can't
pronounce anything to save my life
have you played boyfriend's dragon
no
i hear it's a crazy game though
i hear it's a crazy game
trying to keep an eye on this screen for
when forte shows up so i can get him in
here
enjoy rifter but i need jack and slide
back
yeah a god of war collection the first
five on ps5
you must be young it's
jumping flash
what i've never heard of jumping flash
let me google this
jumping
flash
video game apparently there was two of
them
is this your
your king huh jumping flash
what is this
it's a crazy looking game man
crazy looking game
guys got me over here looking at some
crazy stuff sly cooper i could see that
that's what i'm saying in
uh mike uh
fury like
that game looks
crazy twist the metal resistance i could
see it twist the metal
i used to really enjoy twisted metal
back in the day
jumping flash was a first person
platformer
does those really work that well though
like just think about the concept of a
first person platformer
i don't think that that works out well i
just don't
forte is almost here guys forte is
almost here
he's almost here
so let's let's see here
jumping flash
it's crazy man
i don't play none of those old games i
just don't
you guys are about to just get over that
i prayed this from software ph is not
true i i think most likely that's true
because that makes sense they've worked
together a lot that makes sense
i always felt like um
the coalition could make an army of two
i always felt like if the coalition got
their hands on an army of two
that would be really beneficial to them
an army of two
make it you know co-op
make it extremely gory just like gears
is
i feel like that would be a good fit
army u2 and coalition
twisted metal black just sold for four
grand that's crazy
and you know what's even insane like you
would have
two people you would have
in terms of the um the
these old copies of games
and then you don't think they're going
to be worth a lot of money in the future
and it turns out to be worth
like a lot of money in the future
heavenly sword was made by ninja theory
you know i've been told about heavenly
sword a lot
but i've never played heavenly sword
is this your king
i really should try it i don't know if
this game aged well though it does look
crazy
it does look crazy guys
i might try i don't know maybe microsoft
will let them fund a second one that
would be interesting
i would be curious to see how that goes
very curious indeed
let me look here
got the god of war man i i know a lot of
you love god of war god of war is a good
game no one can take that away from them
god of war is a phenomenal game
a lot of people don't like the new god
of war god of war 2016
but i've always enjoyed like the concept
of it sure
is it different a different god of war
yes it's definitely a different god of
war
but i don't think that that means
that it's not god a war
if that makes sense to you guys
gonna turn my camera off for a couple
minutes
gotta wait for forte man
trying to find where he oh here he is
legend of dragoon i could definitely
i would love for that to come back
legends dragoon
i got a sony
6400 sony a6400
what sucks is always have to like
constantly readjust it
always having to readjust it
you there forte
where you at forte
yeah everything he should definitely i
should be able to hear him
i should be able to hear him look at all
these technical difficulties man
yeah i do think we we do need a legend
of dragoon
um we need that we need that in our life
legend of dragoon is like a huge
type of uh game that i think a lot of
people would enjoy having back
is that forte
yeah cognito acting like
okay he got he left
oh my
gosh play falconer i don't think i'm
playing that
man don't think i'm playing that
i just don't like the way falconer looks
i just i'm gonna be real with you i just
don't falcon here looks like really
weird
invite jazz please the grind my gears
dude we want to balance discourse
look man
might have to to to refrain from that
look i got nothing against some of the
playstation people
but you know it can get it can get
pretty chaotic sometimes man it can get
pretty chaotic sometimes
i could probably get chess gordon i
could definitely get him on the act like
it's definitely one of those
long things you know it's
it's not something that
i could just hit him up on the last
moment
jazz corn is actually a pretty busy dude
he's a pretty busy dude
so i guess we'll
i'll give him maybe another two or three
minutes and
we'll just go ahead and start the
podcast without him even if i have to do
the whole thing by myself it is what it
is
it is what it is
any thoughts on the new madden has
anyone got any thoughts on the new
madden
anyone
i don't think you you're strong enough
on your own no cap i appreciate it but i
like bouncing off people man i like
bouncing off people
call ran
nah i'm not gonna
not gonna interrupt people man if anyone
it would be it would be a playstation
dude what playstation dude should i put
on this show
which one
which playstation dude should i put on
this show
curious what you guys opinion on
it
ran is an xbox dude
is i'm having issues with the uh
what's going on
call king
nah
it's gonna be a just uh i could probably
get big cloud
let me see let's see what you guys want
man
calling
crap gamer
i don't know about all that
i don't know about all of that
hmm
i don't
i send him another message
optimus code i can get optimus code on
blaze 4k jtech tv jdub
big cloud
call me nav
look i got i got like if i have people
on the show man i gotta you know i gotta
what's the word i'm looking for
gotta
gotta vent them first man i can't just
let anyone on here people are are pretty
crazy in these streets man
pretty crazy in these streets
let me look here
alright so i guess we'll just go ahead
and start
uh i don't know what happened to forte
uh he seems to be in the wind somewhere
we're not going to uh you know we're not
gonna put too much thought process into
it man
keemstar look man we ain't having
keemstar on either keemstar don't even
know who we are
so i definitely um
appreciate the patience man
so let's go ahead and talk about this
phil spencer interview
so let's let's talk chat let's talk
about the phil spencer interview how do
you guys feel about the phil spencer
interview for those of you that don't
know
he was i think it was games radar if i
remember correctly
uh to me
he was just on there talking about you
know
uh let's let's let's let's set it up
first man let's set it up first
so what happened is he came on there and
he was pretty much like
you know
what we want to talk about is
we want to talk about whether or not
playstation
[Music]
their type of games and he he did bring
up nintendo so we can't act like he
didn't bring up nintendo
like what type of games that they're
that they need
and um you know
the phil spencer he answered it in a way
that people would expect him to answer
it he was pretty much like look
we can't act like
people don't want
these type of games
so his word is like look we don't need
to make clones of their games
uh if anything game pass it's got to be
a very diverse thing
it's going in and out what do you mean
it's going in and out does anyone else
see my my audio going in and out
or is it or is it just him
you there forte
i don't
know all right so we'll wait for him man
we'll wait for him so pretty much
what he was saying is he was just like
look like
we want to make as diverse libraries
possible and that's the only way that
something like game pass works
is
game pass has to be as diverse as
possible so they can get as many types
of audiences
subscribing to that as possible so
that's that's how that works and i don't
think people really
you know
they really you know thought that too
much through
can you hear me forte yeah i hear you
hear me now i can't yeah i can hear you
jesus man i had my rest in peace my
astro a50s
yeah maybe i just need to reach maybe i
just need to reset them yeah you stop i
did do do you um can you hear me yeah i
hear you people in the chat said i keep
going in and out i don't know man maybe
you guys need to check your uh
yo are you gonna tell these people they
need to check their stuff man you can't
be telling me yeah man look man
sometimes it's not me it's them all
right sometimes it's not me it's them
what did they
what did they teach you a long time ago
the customer is always right meaning
your fans are always right look man you
have been in
the retail market for a while i'm sure
there's days where you you know that
that that that's not that's not there's
there's times where i'm like i frown
upon that phrase but for about ninety
percent of the time it's actible
all right so all right so let's first
off let's let's break this down man
let's let's go in uh what's going on the
the phil spencer interview they did say
that they wanted us to talk about the uh
the xbox game pass hurt sales but we're
gonna let we're gonna let you guys wait
on that here in a minute because i've
already started talking about this phil
spencer interview i know you you
definitely watched that phil spencer
interview there's no way you didn't yeah
i watched it
like what what was your initial thoughts
when you saw that that interview
uh
i mean the biggest thing for me was i
mean
for phil for me
because i didn't check out the whole
thing was the whole clip was the whole
thing about um about that one thing or
that he dive into some other tip because
i didn't check out the whole interview
the whole interview wasn't exactly like
there was multiple things i mean he even
you know brought up the the billions of
gamers stuff right but it was mainly so
what particular thing are you talking
about could i do i want to talk about
when he was talking about the comparison
to playstation and nintendo games
man those game
so
look everybody this is the whole thing
that i always try to tell people you
can't expect
everybody to be the same like nintendo
brings a particular
asset to the market when it comes to
their games you know that more family
oriented
you know um pretty much pick up and play
a game that we've been playing since
1980 and then sony has you know their
cinematic
third person type of games that they
make they also have jrpgs which xbox did
a really good job in um trying to bring
not probably not the jrpgs they have
bring a lot of that stuff over to their
servicing game pass but they are trying
to bridge that gap when it comes to just
rpgs in general um
a lot of people will tell you that they
have some of the best
rpg makers in the business now
underneath the xbox umbrella
so i think they've done a really really
good job in doing that and i think but
the thing is people just you can't
expect
xbox to be what everybody else is you
know everybody else brings something
particular to the table that is benefits
to them
and um i think xbox is still fighting
her way when it comes to that and i
think we're going to see that over the
course of the um
the next couple of years um we're asking
a lot of my i mean look i'm not gonna
i'm not trying to sugarcoat and say that
we shouldn't expect greatness from xbox
because we should they went out and
spent this money on these um studios and
people want to see exactly what these
studios are going to bring and breed to
fruition
but
we at like these studios were just
purchased two years ago or i mean like
you know four years ago you know this is
still a work in progress ever since 2018
and then you add in a pandemic that has
kind of just put everything on hold for
like a good year it looks like a
two-year window now
so
i like exactly what he has to say those
things are coming it's just gonna it
mean the we don't wanna we don't wanna
say it but it's just gonna take time and
it's a lot of stuff that's happening in
the outset but i just think in general
they're all different and i think that
is something that a lot of people are
probably just gonna just glance over
because they'll be like well sure they
are different but in general it just
comes back to
what do you play xbox for
i play for the multiplayer experience i
play because of my friends that are on
that platform i feel like xbox has one
of the best um
um
one of the best services when it comes
to
just online infrastructure that there is
you know playstation's not too far
behind
but playstation is more about the single
player experience now some people are
going to say that's blasphemous i play
call of duty over there i play destiny
over there i play all these games on my
playstation 5 and my playstation 4. but
that's not what the community is built
around you know everybody i can go on my
playstation 5 right now and
not most of the people over there aren't
in parties you know they're playing
games by themselves which is nothing
wrong with but i'm not used to that type
of infrastructure when it comes to xbox
because i can if i want to play by
myself i can but for the most part i'm
playing with other people
do you think that
it's mainly like you know when we talk
because i get the same thing you know
i i don't feel like playstation is more
social than xbox but do you think right
that's just because we're not on
playstation full-time like that like you
know maybe like jabari in them they're
always in parties and you know
playstation feels social to them because
they're always there but like to me like
it's it's a pain to even get in parties
on what that's the thing yeah like well
yeah they completely changed the system
like
when it was playstation 4 granted i
wasn't in parties like that on
playstation 4. but i don't even me i
don't matter of fact now that i think
about it i have not been in a
playstation 5 party since i had my
playstation 5. just because it's so
convoluted to actually get people into a
party like you have to start up a party
um even if you're not and then say if
your friends have a group that they're
already in a party with they have to
send you an invite to it and all this
other stuff and then or or they got to
start a completely new party and you
know that's that's that's neither here
or there i do agree with you though i do
think people like you know barry and
persona and jw and you know all those
people that do play on playstation they
will argue against the fact that there
is a community over there but
i think it's just the fact that our
level of community was based on
2001 when xbox live first launched and
we built a
like not a following but just a
understanding of what that ecosystem
looks like and the one thing that
microsoft hasn't really let us down on
is the ecosystem of xbox live you know
when it comes to the games yes but for
the people keep forgetting predominantly
90 of the games you play a third party
and we have some really good third-party
games over the course of the last couple
of generations that
really helped us
make it through the the the doldrums of
what xbox was giving us it wasn't that
we just chose to play on xbox we were
just used to the experience of being
social with people on xbox and it's the
same thing for people on playstation if
you never came over to xbox and you
stayed on playstation you will argue the
opposite thing it's just that it is kind
of widely known that xbox live has kind
of been a standard and playstation
basically really picked that up during
the um last generation
i agree with you to a point you know
there's a i i think that people don't
give call of duty enough props like i
might not like call of duty but
call of duty really pushed the you know
the playstation the xbox
really big on the xbox it pushed the the
whole first person shooter market
forward yeah but yeah and i feel like
you don't get that same thing but you
know let's let's backpedal a little bit
like when it comes to phil spencer like
i don't necessarily think he was saying
we're not going to make these type of
games like i think he was just saying
we need game pass to be a diverse
platform we don't need to do what
playstation's doing exactly and you know
because playstation doesn't have to
worry about having multiple different
genres because they're focusing on one
genre that's really popular
so you know to me that's that's why
playstation doesn't switch things up a
whole whole lot but at the same time
microsoft does have to worry about that
they do have to worry about getting all
these variety of different games into
game pass and keeping all of these
different gamers happy with these type
of games so they continue to subscribe
to game pass
and that's why they bought as many
studios as they bought we're seeing you
know the the a little bit of the fruits
of the labor it probably in the next
year
but i don't think that you know he came
out there and he was just saying yo
forte
they just make them so well we're not
even gonna try like i don't think that's
how that went i think for the most part
they're going to make those type of
games but it's not gonna be to the
degree that some playstation fanboys
want
because when some of these playstation
fanboys talk you would really feel like
they only play one type of game
they never play anything else
and when they see a game that's not that
type of game they're automatically
turned off by and they don't want to
play it
and i don't and
look
gaming is a very selfish thing very very
selfish hobby but at the same time we do
got to realize that
not everybody likes that type of
gameplay
i i think that microsoft wants their
bread and butter to be rpgs would you
not agree with that
uh that's what they wanted to be now
here let me take care of somebody that's
in the
chat you gots to go brother i don't know
what's going on with you remove you
but um
no i i agree i
like i said the biggest thing that it
always comes back to is like like i said
xbox doesn't have to be what everybody
else is they just need to be xbox and
xbox just need to figure out exactly
what
you know their new
normal is you know it was shooters it
was online
multiplayer now they have game pass
where they have to diverse a lot more of
the portfolio on top of what they're
doing inside the game pass but in the
acquisition not acquisitions but in the
um
acquiring of games that go into the
service that are gonna fit the service
the way they want it to fit uh that's
why i said last week on brap i think a
game like um when they go to gamescom i
think a game like aliens fire team would
be a really good game for game pass
because
it fits the narrative of what game pass
is you know just like outriders did and
everything else games like that the
social aspect not saying it's going to
happen but those are the type of games
and experiences actually right now that
fit that narrative until microsoft comes
up with a solution of how they want to
nurture that across the um
across the whole player base
yeah and you know it's like i said like
i feel like
game pass is going to open doors to a
lot of things that normally wouldn't
happen doors open i feel like you know
indy's going to feel a little bit more
comfortable making games if they can
already get in game pass
because
we've seen especially indies like
they they make a lot of their profit off
just game pass
like if they're able to get their gaming
game pass they've already pretty much
funded their project
so you know i think we'll see more of
that in the future
um you know just real quick before we go
on to the next topic uh do you think
that though that microsoft wants this
engine starts throwing out first person
uh not first person games but the first
uh
first party games do you think that
we'll see more uh the same amount of
games coming into game pass that we see
now or do you think that once they get
these games out of their first party
starting to come out pretty consistently
you think they'll fall back a little bit
i think it's the opposite i think
instead of them having the chase games
different game pass i think those
studios and those publishers will want
to be in game pass then because
right now third party is pretty much
carrying game pass now that will
probably change a little bit during the
holidays because you got games like halo
and forza going into it day and date
but the more xbox get games in there and
the more that they get their
subscription numbers up just by
harvesting the games that they actually
have and they produce if they can grow
this to 30 40 50 million with just their
games then you're going to see those
third parties saying yo we want to be in
game pass you you know what does it take
for us to be in there versus xbox going
to them saying hey what would it take
for us to get your game to come into
this service i think a lot of um i think
a lot of studios a lot of publishers
want their games to go in there but they
don't want to be the main draw and they
want to be other reasons for people to
go in there because then it keeps people
subscribed to the subscription because
more downloads they get depending on the
deal they got with xbox they can get uh
more eyes on their games and stuff or
more revenue based on how many downloads
and clicks they get so i do i think it's
twofold i just think that if xbox puts
out better games and they get more of
their games in there that's gonna bring
more third party because it's like the
rich gets richer at that point
yeah i agree with you i think you know
i personally feel like they'll cool back
a little bit on terms of like you know i
don't think we'll see a lot of mlb the
shows i think the indies
i think the indies will definitely still
be there now when it comes to like the
stuff you sound like mlb and outriders i
think they might see one or two a year
yeah unless the unless those third
parties come to them like maybe a brand
new ip that they want to debut in game
pass i probably wouldn't you probably
wouldn't see
i i i i dig the different mlb i think
mlb and sports games um
depending on how mlb did and depending
how some of these other games do um that
do launch in there i think you could see
that becoming a norm because they are
just annual updates and we always say
the best sports game would be a updated
sports game every year instead of having
to pay that 60 bucks every year to get
something like that and i think services
like game pass or even playstation now
can definitely um benefit games like
that but when it comes to like those
bigger third-party games unless it's a
brand new ip i do agree with you you'll
see less of those but indie games you'll
get a bunch of those
yeah so you know speaking of you know
games in general and exclusives
looks like
playstation might having an old game
come back man sly cooper has been
rumored to be coming back into the
ecosystem first off do you believe this
rumor because how many years have sly
cooper almost been coming back coming
back not coming back like i feel like
this is like people's go-to keep in mind
we're talking about playstation insiders
too
so you know we we got it we got to keep
that with a greatness
and i mean a great assault like the
whole damn bin assault keep keep in mind
uh that this isn't really official by
any means whatsoever it's just when i
did see that i did think
that would be a good game to come back
and i feel like uh playstation letting
that come back would prove to me that
they are going to still take chances
because it does look like they want to
go more towards the if we can't make
money and it's not highly uh rated we're
not doing it so i feel like if they if
they brought back sly
i would feel more comfortable
in the fact that they are going to take
these risks
that these games might not necessarily
sell the greatest but they do want to
introduce and be diverse in their
platform what do you feel about sly
cooper coming back and do you do you
feel like if it's a true thing or not
no it it definitely should be a thing
the biggest thing is what was uh thieves
the time was on ps3 right that was the
last time they released it right
so honestly it just comes back to
those are the type of games that
are really hit or miss it just depends
on
it's it's got a it's got a cult
following but how big is the cult
following you know at a certain point it
comes back to like with xbox people want
people we keep saying oh man they should
bring back conquer but how many people
actually want to play conquer
that's what it comes out i've always
felt like conquer will bomb if it comes
by but that's what it comes down to so
would it be a great gesture to bring
this game back you know bring the
trilogy back bring sly cooper um
collection or something just like they
did with ratchet and clank and
everything like that i think that would
be cool um bringing it back as a
playstation collection game would be
another thing
but ultimately really comes down to
unless they're going to remake these
games i mean probably not part three
because part three still looks pretty
good because it was on the vita and it
was on um playstation 3 so it's not that
old but unless you're going to remake
the first to second one it kind of just
comes back to that whole
you know why why can't we just play ps3
games on our ps5 digitally at this point
so
i think they need to remake them not
remaster them because they are a little
bit older
but it also just comes back to what
people are interested in this just like
it is for xbox and a whole bunch of
their games banjo kazooie a lot of
people want that how many people are
actually going to play it
you know we saw that we saw the numbers
for we saw the numbers for eternal we're
not going there oh no well yeah we're
not going to get i know you love
banjo-kazooie definitely look if they
could put banjo-kazooie on uh smash
brothers they can definitely bring it
back to xbox i actually feel like
banjo-kazooie came back with a good
budget and a good team making it
it like okay they don't want to remake
like a if they don't want to make a
third one okay
but i do feel like if they've redone the
first one from the ground up in a new
engine like unreal engine 5 like i feel
like it would do well i feel like you
know we have been in a little bit of a
decline in terms of of platformers like
we have some but not a whole lot and
especially on xbox we don't have a whole
lot of platforms on xbox in general so i
think our high quality banjo would open
up a lot of eyes that some of these
older ips can
last and keep in mind like banjo is a
very cartoony looking game so i think
you know in game pass it would reach to
a an audience in terms of you know uh
some kids
will speak to that it would speak to
that nintendo crowd of gamers that
always wondered like oh what games can i
play on my playstation on my xbox that
are you know more kid friendly and i
always tell people
there's a couple but for the most part
you just want to get a switch
if you want to be on the safe side when
it comes to that um but
the thing really comes back to me is
who's going to make this game who would
actually make this game because we know
sucker punch is the original architect
of it but they're busy with you know
games like go to zashima and other
things like that i think they're they're
they're focused forward um they had the
uh what is it said zero studios of games
they made the um games from 2010 to
2013.
so who really knows what's going to
happen with that they got to have a
studio that actually can produce these
games they got they just acquired nexus
now that's one avenue to remaster the
games or redo the games to be brought up
to playstation 5 or even over the
playstation 4.
yeah but they haven't well yeah i mean
if they actually come out and announce
that finally that they accidentally put
up a you know
a screenshot of the wrong studio it just
say we acquired bluepoint at this point
it would be a playstation studio they
wouldn't go that's a thing there would
have to be a playstation studio that
does it because i don't see
playstation going out of their way to
hire and uh contract that out to a third
party
because they don't know how good the
game is going to sell on on its own at
least if they do it internally
they lose a little bit less money i
think they will sell a lot of them it
just depends on how much they're
actually looking that they would do
give me three seconds yeah but you know
i mean guys i mean i asked you guys the
question you know they did bring games
like um
uh what was the name of that game
what was the name of the game that that
they remade three times they made it for
um
they made it for playstation 3
playstation 4 they remastered it a
couple of times
with the um
the giants in it um
you think the name of it um
causal yeah shadow of colossus they
remade that game multiple times like you
would think if they can re now granted
that game isn't is more geared towards
the hardcore a little bit more
um not so much and i'm not going to say
the sly cooper is geared towards the
younger audience but it has a younger
audience appealed by the aesthetic of
the game but then again you've got games
like ratchet and clink that are the same
way they appeal more to a younger crowd
even knowing older people do play them
so they they pick and choose the games
that they want to do i just don't know
what kind of sales sly had behind it for
them to do it but it would be nice to do
um they showed it the capacity to
actually bring back old ips and you know
try to revitalize them so anything can
really happen with this one
i feel like
if anyone's to do this it would be
playstation because it does feel like
you know they they do value
their older games a little bit more than
xbox and not necessarily xbox doesn't
value them like you know they put a lot
of money a lot of time a lot of research
and development behind you know
backwards compatibility they're always
trying to find ways to improve older
games but as far as like bringing back
an older game and like putting a lot of
money behind it i feel like playstation
does seem to do that a little bit better
uh because they have a whole studio
dedicated to it
so uh you know i'm curious to see you
know because i do think microsoft is
making a banjo it's j i'm just curious
when it would come out
to me
at this point you've seen mad people
talk about it
there's no reason not to do it because i
don't feel like
i feel like a high budgeted banjo
it's still like a low budgeted aaa game
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think you'd have to take a whole lot of
time doing it and it's like i mentioned
earlier man if you feel like it's too
much of a risk
putting that kind of money out to really
do the game
uh you know justice and make a sequel
just remake the first one from the
ground up reimagine it too you could add
some stuff to it just don't do don't get
too crazy because i don't like when
studios
you know they they go a little bit too
extra
who makes it for xbox
i think
rare already said they ain't doing it
yeah but rare's leadership said they
ain't doing it that's true i feel like
if you went there and you found someone
passionate about it
like you know
like someone that's been there a while
that that's just looking for an
opportunity to make his name and you
you know and then you went to double
fine and uh you know you asked some
people over there who would want to make
it because they have a lot of uh
interesting and platform and you just
have like a like those two studios maybe
you know people from both studios come
together and make banjo
and you know then after you get that you
know
that core audi that core developing
scene
then what you do is you hire a couple
more people to help them
and you know i think that it would
really benefit them
a lot to have that game uh because at
the end of the day i do think we need
something like a ratchet and clank on
playstation on xbox not necessarily that
i think this is what
what phil spencer's talking
like we don't need to make that type of
ratchet and clank game
but they do have stuff like
banjo that could be they're kind of a
ratchet and clank game but not copy and
playstation
and i think that you know phil spencer
wants to do more of that than he wants
to just copy a formula because it's
successful you know i think what's a
valve comes out once the elder scrolls
comes out what's
starfield comes out you're going to see
a lot more people back off of microsoft
needs to make type of sony games because
the main thing people want to see right
now is just make good games in general
and i think once play microsoft starts
putting out decent to really good games
such as avow
you know fable perfect art you'll start
to see more people
have less and less to say you know what
i'm saying
yeah
so
obviously man we got to talk about
the bread and butter because i feel like
this this is going to be a 30 minute
conversation because this will be the
most dumbest 30 could be the
conversation we ever gonna have but
let's go
so
did you first of all did you check out
did you did you check out the uh the
twitter space today
no i was asleep oh man
what's funny is like
i was listening to and i fell asleep
that's probably one of the amazing
reasons you tell us that's not
necessarily talking about anyone there
i've worked in eight to twelve
uh 12 to eight so i was working off
eight hours then i went to the gym right
after that worked out for about an hour
and a half
then i came home
and passed out on my bed because i
wanted to hear the conversation i didn't
get to hear a whole lot of it did you
hear a lot of it
i caught the last 30 40 like last 30
minutes like last 20 minutes of it
look all right let's let's break this
down first off i want to point out that
i invited code onto here to defend his
points because i know
code's always extra about everything i
wanted some form of a balancing beam and
a low key i wanted me and forte to team
up on code but you know he decided he he
decided that
you know he didn't want to respond to my
aunt my messages this man responds to my
messages all the time but for this
particular time he was ghost i'm not
saying yo man code was hiding from
addict but i'm saying he was hiding from
addicts so you know uh i'm sure
i'm gonna probably try to get code on
here next week uh i got i gotta i gotta
break down stuff i gotta find out what's
in code's mind man i i gotta do it
it code be saying some off the wall
stuff on on on twitter i gotta find out
how the mind of code
works so let's let's talk about this man
they came out
as in people who can fly that's the
people who make outriders it's very
important to distinguish the people who
make it and the people who published it
and they said they haven't got any
royalties
from square enix and then what's the
first thing people say well this game
came on game pass
so automatically people assumed that
because of the
being on game pass the cells was lacking
so that's why they're not paying
royalties because they haven't made
their expectation keep in mind forte
this is the same company that said
as in square enix because now i'm
talking about square enix this is the
same company that dropped the bomb on
marvel
this is the same company that said they
needed eight million copies and that was
their expectations for tomb raider
so all
all these years
people have been saying
score enix is out of a mind
but now
when they don't make expectations with a
game
and because that game so happened to be
on game pass
now it's issues
now
it's game pass is bombing the sales
which is funny
forte tell me throughout the past four
or five years even before game pass what
was a lot of these playstation fanboys
were saying
xbox people don't buy games they don't
buy games so now
they want these is the same people
wanting me to think
the missing component to these games
selling
is xbox gamers not buying them
i thought we didn't buy games so why
does it matter like
let me hear your opinion on this man
because th this is some of the craziest
stuff i've seen in a while
yo so
it's crazy
okay yeah it's great it's crazy for me
you know being a person that has gay
past have it all the way to 2023
not ashamed of it i ain't buying no
gains if i ain't got to if it's going to
show up in game pass i'll wait for it
now if it's not gonna be a gay pass i'm
gonna be there day one and i'm gonna
still buy it day one i just never
understood the argument around people
that want to save money i have people
that walk into the store every day
asking for a deal on something like hey
is it possible you could do it for this
price it's a little bit cheaper look man
that's just the way of just
everything people no one wants to pay
full price so everybody to be out here
acting like
this whole
they're all
um what's the word i'm looking for
they're all like
above it all when it comes to like
spending money i'm like no listen man
people spend money on the things that
they like if you if you are if you are a
fan of a particular thing you're going
to spend money on it no matter what it
has nothing to do about 70 games or
anything like that because that's just a
bunch of capping it's just the fact that
game pass is a great service and it
allows people to try games that they
probably normally wouldn't have tried
before and going back to this whole
outriders thing
i didn't hear maybe outriders didn't do
as well as they thought it probably
should have did is because your game
didn't work ninety percent of the time
let's be for real here you had to get
you you had prime time real estate i
literally gave you the front of the
store i i put i let you put your game in
the front glass
everybody that walked by the store saw
it and they had an opportunity to try to
download it and play it for their
membership price and what happened
people's inventories were disappearing
shout out to lord cognito for giving
them a week which actually took two
weeks almost an entire month for him to
get his stuff back i still to this day
can't log into the game so i just
completely stopped playing the game in
general so
maybe that has a lot to do with the fact
that you know your game didn't do as
well because the public outcry for not
being able to participate in the game
that's part of a service might have just
went completely poof
and they just said i'm not i'm not about
to eat i'm not about to recommend this
game to nobody anymore
it's stuff like that
to me
this is just
this game was made as hell from the
start got a lot of good concepts a lot
of good going for great foundation that
i would love for them to build off of
but the game came out busted
uh what's the one of the number one
things that's that sell games word of
mouth
uh unless you was on game pass i wasn't
selling this to anyone
yo yo tell me why i should should buy
out writer's addict
it does
it it crashes all the time
oh no man what did you hear what did you
hear most people on twitter saying like
even even recently like a month ago not
even a month ago like two weeks ago
people were saying yo man all right this
was fun i i liked it but you know i'm
glad i didn't pay for that because i
would be pissed if i had to spend 60
bucks in the game that i barely got a
chance to play for the last month
i think
if anything
and i know this is going to be crazy
i think if anything
game pass helped this game oh it
absolutely did it did more than people
think it did
i think game pa game pass sold more
copies than people let on
for some reason people think millions
upon millions upon millions upon
millions of xbox games is going to buy
this game in the first place we don't
have that information
we don't know who was going to buy this
game who wasn't going to buy this game
for all we know
this game was going to bomb on xbox just
like it bombed on playstation
but the only difference is
is you could arguably say if we knew how
much money that they paid at uh score
enix to get this game you could arguably
say that they might have made more money
off xbox than they made off playstation
because of the influence of cash that
they got for putting these game pass
like to me we don't have enough
information to say this or to say that
it's like look like
we don't know for all we know square
enix could just be doing what
corporations do best whole day money
i mean we've seen multiple companies
throughout the years do whatever they
can to to to pay the developers bonuses
and stuff have they not
so no this could literally just be score
edicts is like you know people can fly
walked up to score ac like yo let me
hold something and square is like
you can hold this plane ticket back to
your place
so
we don't know what's going on i don't
think game pass that if anything i think
game pass helped to get to more
audiences
to me
gamepass got a lot of
game pass gave
outriders a lot more wiggle room because
it was in game pass
because if this game would have dropped
the way it was the people that
are playing this on game pass that they
would have bought this a lot of them
would return the game
but because it's on game pass people
didn't really have that option
uh because they didn't pay for it so
they didn't have to return it
i think that there's a lot of things
going on here that people aren't aren't
looking
and at the end of the day uh i don't
think game pass could be held
responsible for this there's multiple
variables saying why this game did what
it did for instance like i said game was
busted at launch
game had game was a good concept
in terms of
how the game should have ran
but it didn't do it well
game had game breaking bugs to where
people didn't have access to the game
that some people actually paid for
game also was published by a company
that has been famous for unexpected for
for unrealistic expectations on terms of
sales
so how is people automatically all of a
sudden through all these years forte
we've always said square enix is is on
something
game after game
remember they said that p uh the uh
final fantasy 15 had to make 15 uh they
had to sell 10 million units
just to make profit or something like
that i don't know but that was it that
could be a unique situation because how
long it took that game to be made but
anyway that's 10 million
to me i feel like they expected more of
outriders than they got
and i know
sure is there people out there that
would have picked that game up
on game pass that would have bought that
game of course i'm not going to say that
this game
didn't have some loss of sales because
it's on game pass i'm saying that there
are people that played this game on game
pass and picked it up those are those
are facts
there are people that would not have
played this game and probably got their
friends to pick this game up because of
what they played in game pass and we
can't imagine the big giant bag that
microsoft dropped off at score edicts to
get this game all game pass people want
to act like that last one doesn't exist
game passes ran like a business they
consider how many how much potential the
game has to succeed on game pass and
they consider how many people would have
bought it and nine times out of ten that
is what they give them keep in mind this
was one of the first
aaa titles if not the first one to come
on game pass so you know they got a bag
bag
this game failed because of the stuff
this game had issues with this game
didn't fail because of game pass
yeah no you're right i i agree um cat
daddy uh or elder cat can't call you cat
daddy man elder cat says um i bought it
on scene and had no regrets and there's
a lot of people like that i
i know shout out to slumbo he bought it
on steam a lot of people bought the game
on different platforms and stuff and it
didn't hurt the game sales anywhere else
you know in it and if everybody
remembers correctly it's still it's
still top the top the chart for xbox the
week it came out in sales now did it
have a long lasting tale something like
uh nba or grand theft auto or even a
ratchet and clank or returnal no because
i think a lot of that had to do with the
fact that the game just wasn't in a good
place i mean within the first month we
saw a bunch of issues with the game and
stuff now if that game ran flawlessly
who knows how many people would buy it
and pick it up and um somebody else said
it um in the chat he was talking about
how once it leaves game pass they
probably get another boost and they're
absolutely right you know once it leaves
game pass the true people that really
love that game and really didn't have
any of the issues that the game had
those people if they still play it like
king and stuff like that they'll
probably go out and still buy the game
day and you know the day it leaves game
pass and they'll recoup a lot of their
sales back that way too but the sit here
and make it seem like game pass did not
help this game
it literally opened up it literally
opened up a possibility for people that
never even thought they even knew what
this game was you know that's what that
that's what game pass did it's not just
about it being oh that game oh xbox
flipped the bill to put it in there xbox
literally opened up another avenue for
people to try game a game that they
probably didn't even have an option or
even thought about playing
you know what's funny too
let's get this fight out of superchat
from uh uh thano rios uh definitely
butcher's your name we're gonna move on
the we need to start separating square
enix from adios uh i think those are the
people that make uh
um he's right about that
they make dave
mankind divided and stuff
does the rpg idiots does outriders tomb
raider etc look i think
square enix just needs to be a better
publisher
i think that they do too much stuff
and they and they're not involved in too
much stuff at the same time i feel like
score enix
is probably most likely i'm going to say
they're definitely the culprit in this
scenario they probably had too high of
expectations and they probably do that
intentionally so they don't have to pay
royalties to the to the degree that they
should have to pay them
you know i'm not going to say that what
they're doing is right or wrong i don't
know what it is i don't know what kind
of contract uh uh you know they've
signed i don't know what any of that but
what i do know
is sometimes these corporations can do
sky me stuff for money and you know
outriders
definitely is one of those things that
i i really enjoyed the concept but it
just wasn't a good game it was average
uh it you know
i think one of the issues that they had
is they didn't want to they didn't want
to step into the games as a service
uh area
they're on twitter saying they're not at
games as a service but they're operating
like a games as a service with patches
and stuff it's like just be honest if
this is a games of service just just
tell us
i feel like some people probably didn't
re-download or didn't bite because they
didn't see like to me when you're
telling people that generally play these
type of games which is your games as a
service type of people that this game
isn't going to be that type of game but
at the same time
because that's the people you're going
to appeal to the destiny folks the
division folks but you're telling those
same people this isn't like destiny this
isn't like division this isn't as a
games as a service you got people like
myself that's like then why should i buy
it
there's no future in this game
yeah
uh shout out to the homeboy randall thor
he just put something on twitter
responding to dreamcast guys saying
uh greek i was talking about how it
bombed it then randall said which is
weird considering square said outriders
was on track to become the company's
next major franchise do you say that if
the game was bombing hard
and i remember i remember them saying
that so
what happened over the course of the
last
two months
after this game came out all the things
that we all the things we talked about
you know
like like elder cat once again talked
about he said dumb nurse um hurt its
longevity put a hundred hours in and
they nerfed all of my um t15 bills i
never went back and elder cat was one of
those people that would bring people
into the game he he actually paid for it
and would actually get people to try the
game out on whatever platform because
guess what it was cross-play compatible
with everything so no matter where you
play you were able to play with people
like him and he even stopped talking
about it so if your hardest core fans
stopped talking about it what you think
going to happen to your long-term sales
keep in mind that is another issue that
they had this game is not functioning
right people are getting locked out of
the screen people aren't being able to
play it people are constantly crashing
every couple minutes and the first thing
they announce is here's the patch notes
here's the loot drop fixes i'm like
say what
game's not working no one cares about
the loots we care about the game working
you know i can understand you could do
two things
but to me
you don't announce it you have two teams
working on both things which technically
to me you should have had everyone on
deck to fix the game but i don't once
again i don't know what goes on behind
closed doors i can't speak for a company
if i'm not part of that company right to
me
i would have just kept the patch notes
on the down low you know right because
to me they were they were trying to fix
the longevity of the game the people use
these exploits and got all the best
stuff in the first couple of
weeks the game's dead you know what i'm
saying but it's like at the same time
that is an environment you created
that's an environment that you
didn't fix when the game was before it
was launched so at the end of the day
that is a sword you're going to have to
fall on
because your priority should be to fix
the game to keep people in the game for
instance if you wouldn't have been doing
all these patch notes and you would have
fixed the game cat daddy would still
have his broken ass combos and he would
still be playing that getting people
into the game
cat daddy could have potentially domino
effect another 10 to 15 000 people to
play that game he gets he brings five to
ten people on a plate yo this game's
good you got game pass you know bite
let's play it he gets he gets 10 people
those 10 people get another 10 people
but when you cut the head off the hydra
and he ain't doing it because of the bad
decisions that you're making
then guess what it never goes anywhere
from there so i said word of mouth sells
more consoles more games than a lot of
people think
and this game was a very hard sell if
you wasn't in game pass in general
yeah
sorry
so
if i
let let's let's break it down if you
would blame anyone who would you blame
like 100
oh if someone had to take all the blame
yes
uh
all the blame i mean look
you can't you really can't give nobody
all to blame i think
p
i think if anything if you want to give
some of the branding divvy it out
because nobody can take 100 of this if
you want to give some of this to xbox 10
of it just because i feel like they
i just i think they should take ten
percent just because of the fact that it
was a game
it's kind of been a narrative with them
when it comes to games launching and
game pass we always want them to do a
little bit better with the quality
control i don't have a problem with the
game yeah that's my only issue like the
quality controls
outriders exactly like it's like come on
man like mike
i love game pass but you do got to start
quality controlling better like i guess
maybe because they they consider some of
these games like real big i like have a
lot of people working on it they don't
have to do that as much what could that
make your service look makes your
service look bad after after so many
games like that you know a lot of people
looked at it kind of funny when a scent
came out and did the same thing games
like out writers did so it's like are
you a service for games or your service
for buggy games that we got to test to
patch out before they actually start
working right is it some of them like
outriders really never work for people
so 10 percent i give to them but then i
i have to give
at least 50
to
people can fly because they're the ones
that built this game
and they were the lords of their own
kingdom when it came to this game they
had all of the accolades where the game
first launched when people were even
when people weren't able to play the
game people liked the game like i like
outriders i love the overall gameplay
loop inside of it but when people
are
met with black screens and jumping in
parties with friends and getting booted
all the way to the dashboard where
you're trying to do some of the hardest
content in the game
it's very disheartening to uh see that
happen and then when you gotta wait like
some people three four weeks for your
inventory to come back
at that point people didn't checked out
so most of the blame has to go to people
can fly when it comes to the game in
general
but but then square even picks up the
rest of it because their expectations of
the game was kind of off what do you
think of fixes to these games being
broken
i'm done with games being needed to be
fixed man i feel like dudes it's
it's too much it just needs to work
it's got to the point where i can
understand maybe one to two a year you
know what i'm saying like you know
multiplayer games having serious
networking issues i usually give them a
pass because you could do internal
testing you could do testing in general
you can't anticipate how many people
you're actually gonna have
but like to me
there's too many games coming out on
like a technical side broken
and i think it's got to be addressed
we're having way too many games we've
had return will do it this year
outriders
a cent
i mean there's probably more i'm just
not thinking it's like look like those
are just three of some of the biggest
games that came out this year and it's
just like where i mean not to mention
last year's fiasco called cyberpunk
i i think that you know if if a game is
broken to this extent that a lot of
these games are
you
i feel like automatically the person who
bought them should be refunded half the
game
and i feel like these platform holders
need to start enforcing stuff like that
or taking it off just taking it off the
the uh
the the store because to me we've gotten
to this point where
no one's checking anyone
microsoft's leading games microsoft
playstation nintendo they're letting
broken games get on their platform
publishers are publishing broken games
intentionally and developers they're the
ones that get the [ __ ] out of the stick
because they don't want the game broken
but they're not giving most of the time
they're not giving enough time to
actually properly make the game
function correctly so it's just like
where is
the time
where it's enough and i think we've been
there for a while
but that's why i have respected
playstation so much
because when that happened sure they did
it for their own selfish reasons
but i saw
i saw potential i saw okay
you know maybe this will start happening
more in the future where if you release
a broken game and there's too much bad
stuff happening guess what we gonna do
we gonna move remove your stuff off the
platform and until it's fixed that's
when it's put back on how many how how
how long you think if that's how if
that's happened you know with every game
that's broke how long do you think it
would take for that for for these games
to come out actually working
i don't have any hope on these games
coming out working as it is already
i think if they knew if they released
broken mess
that microsoft steam playstation and
nintendo would yank their [ __ ] off of
their platform so fast until it's fixed
they would de-list it i think they would
stop doing this
i think they would stop doing it i think
people would would naturally delay the
game because it needs to be delayed
because it's it it's more beneficial to
get those sales of the game not getting
de-listed than it is for them to release
it then it's broken mess
then they get it de-listed
and i think that you know that is going
to hit them more than anything else but
at the end of the day
why would playstation people why would
xbox people and why would nintendo
people intentionally do less games that
they make 30 percent off of
so it's it's a rough thing man it's a
rough thing you know
got a bonus topic for you man got a
bonus
let's go
bonus topic let's go
game pass
obviously we were talking about you know
quality control of game pass but
i don't think
i think games like hades
is going to be the prime example why
game pass is so successful like
hades is such a good game and i want to
talk about hades for a couple minutes
because like
i
let me let me clear the air when it
comes to my maternal
versus
hades message
for all the playstation people in that
comment section they got an issue with
that hold that l
because at the end of the day
nothing i said was wrong
all i said was look in my opinion
i can understand why
hardcore roguelike people said return
was missing a lot of roguelike features
and to me
i personally feel like hades is a better
game than return
there was nothing wrong with that
statement you will never make me think
there's anything wrong with that
statement
and i personally just feel like look
like hades has a lot going for it and
you don't really like i didn't play a
whole lot of role like games forte i
didn't know what to look for
right but hades has such a good
environment like it's so good that i'm
like
i can see why it got elected for game of
the year
like it's it's definitely one of those
things that like you know
we need more games like that man like i
want microsoft i want people to really
start trying to go above and beyond
to
fund more of these type of games you
know what i'm saying
and you know
what do you what is your opinion on uh
on hades and do you think that you know
we we can expect more
really popular popular
you know uh
really popular indie games to come in
game pass like keep in mind 12 minutes
is coming out friday yep
and i think that's going to be an
interesting game hopefully it'll work a
lot of people been looking forward to it
so what is your opinion on all that
uh i played on switch it was great then
it's great now i haven't got a chance to
boot it up actually i haven't installed
i'm looking at the title screen right
now on xbox um i watched a couple people
streaming and play it it's um
it's incredible it was a
great uh experience to play through the
initial time
i just think in general when i saw him
coming to game pass i was like okay now
this is the type of game that you
definitely want to see
inside a game pass i think super giant
did an amazing job with the aesthetic of
the game with the systems in the game um
everything flowed together very nicely
combat is very satisfying it just really
comes down to
are you a type of person that likes
games like this and that's kind of seems
to be the kind of crutch with the whole
situation you know especially when it
comes back to return
people either love it or they hate it
there's really no in between when it
comes to like certain types of road
lights and stuff but from the from the
moment i played it the first time on
switch i was like this is a great game
when they did
game of the year uh last year and i saw
it up there i was like yo
that game has a really good chance of
winning it just has some really stiff
competition versus the other games that
was on that list that it was coming out
against but um
this is the type of game that they
definitely want in game pass this is the
type of games that they need in game
pass they kind of just need to buffer
the overall quality
of some of the games lately that have
been hitting the service because you
know
games like uh death's door would have
been a great not saying it should have
been in game pass but uh indie games
like
the quality yeah exactly that's it the
depth door that's the perfect type of
game like quality wise that should be in
game pass doesn't mean it had to be
there but those are the type of games
that we want to see in there and it
doesn't
and the one thing i kind of been
noticing about like bigger third-party
games is
most of them always it's like
such big budget so
time restraints you know the whole
sickie that's going on around in the
world
a lot of people
it's a lot of pressure on these
developers to get these games out
there's a lot of pressure on these
publishers to get these games out and i
know we want to see these bigger games
like battlefield and you know not
uncharted but battlefield and um
um
over not over we're saying out writers
and stuff in there mlb and stuff like
there
but you know maybe those are the games
that we kind of need to steer clear of
for the time being until
we get you know a little bit more
control around those games because we
don't know what we're going to get from
a third-party perspective when it comes
to these bigger games compared to these
smaller you know more crafty experiences
like hades and death's door
you kind of know what you're going to
get and then like you said when 12
minutes comes out i kind of expect it to
be the same thing and if it isn't then
it would just be another smudge on
what's going on with microsoft in
general but overall i think this is the
direction they should go in because i
think once they're third once their
first party starts um releasing games
you're going to see a
higher quality ceiling at least we hope
when it comes to microsoft first party
games and then all the indie games they
fill it in on the back end with
you know so speaking of game pass uh did
you
see the speculation going on in the
destiny community that
uh this uh because on the 23rd i think
the 23rd to 24th wednesday stream yeah
new season
so apparently it's rumored that what's
that rumor there's like a lot of
speculation going on right now that
that they're gonna announce that uh
witch queen is going in a game pass day
and date you think that might happen
look man
ever since game pass ever since
destiny went into game pass
xbox went from being the least well
outside the stadium went from being the
least played platform to being tight for
the first and second play platform of
all the all of uh the platforms it's on
um it went from being sub 250 000 people
playing it daily to well over three
hundred and fifty thousand sometimes
eclipsing four hundred thousand which is
higher than the playstation four version
of the game is so gamepad's definitely
helped
the xbox when it comes to game pass and
just destiny in general so it's kind of
the symbiotic relationship
but i also know that they have some
stuff coming up next season when it
comes to
a lot of the halo stuff like the battle
the pistol and stuff that kind of got
leaked in there some skins and stuff so
a lot of that stuff that they you know
kind of coincides with something like
this with witchcraft being announced to
probably come in their day and day
uh i don't think bungie lost in this at
all because the game is already free to
play for the most part and all you're
doing is giving away a dlc to what
33 of your player base because everybody
else has to pay for it on other
platforms
yeah and i think you know
we all know well i don't know if
everyone knows but uh bungie is working
on another game it's like code name
matter or something like that
and um i do think that you know the
studios stretch thin
uh they're trying to you know constantly
work on destiny and you know work on
matter as well so i think microsoft
probably pulled in there it's like yo
if you you let me
you let that game pass you know you keep
that that destiny on game pass you know
i'll i'll i'll help you i'll help you
fund destiny i think you know uh
conversations like that might be
happening because obviously it's not
cheap to make games man it's not cheap
to make games
yeah but they're making a lot of money
off of microtransactions i'm gonna tell
you myself in general i
i buy the emotes every season
i haven't had i bought the season
initially before i hit game pass because
i have it on playstation i mean that
playstation i have it on
xbox for game pass and i have it on pc2
so i have it in both places i also buy
all of the um emotes and stuff that they
have that are tied to the seas that
gives you silver and stuff and i know a
lot of people that do that type of stuff
too
and not only does that help xbox it also
helps bungie and who knows what kind of
contractual id um benefits they have
with each other it could be a situation
where bungie for every piece of silver
they sell microsoft doesn't charge them
any type of uh fees for it you know
which is thirty percent on every piece
of dlc that's bought so just to be more
beneficial to them than than getting a
paycheck they get a paycheck because you
have one of the premier games inside the
service
which brings people into that service
that they can spend money on other games
and they get a chance to play other
games that are in that service they can
definitely like use that it's like look
like
what we can do for you is like
going game pass
in any any micro transaction that's
bought
you you keep all hundred percent but
like i feel like they would probably
still take 30 for the game itself like
if well yeah they would still if
somebody bought it off of a pass they
would still probably take the 30
that thirty percent that they would give
them
for
for the micro transit jackson's like
they getting a hundred percent of their
micro transactions that would make any
company think twice you know what i'm
saying like
it's like oh you know like that's pure
profit right there the micro transaction
side of it
not having to pay microsoft that 30
percent
getting getting all the money for the
micro transactions which is going to be
the bulk of the money at this point
and and the funny thing is we came up
with that at the top of our heads
there's no way you can't tell me that
some
publisher and game out there does not
have that deal
somebody had somebody has it i don't
know who said these deals was
i mean i think the most public we're
gonna get is when phil spitzer came out
and actually said that you know it's not
a one size um shoe fits all you know he
said there's multiple different deals
for depending on the scale of the game
the size of the game type of game that
it is
so i guarantee you some studio and i
wouldn't put it past bungie to have some
type of deal like that um
uh i know some like they said some deals
are around downloads and how many people
tried the game you know once they hit a
certain threshold they get a big payout
for microsoft on how many people
downloaded the game and tried it uh so i
think there's all types of different uh
algorithms out there that they're
actually using but it just really comes
down to
microsoft has a lot of different ways to
get people into the ecosystem when it
comes to game fast from a publishing
standpoint and it's always a great thing
for people
yeah you know i think we're going to see
more of that in the future you know i i
do personally feel like you know
everyone that feels like
game pass is not in a good position
uh i think you guys are delusional i
don't think you're really paying
attention
uh i do feel hilarious that you know
some people
they go on and on all day long every day
24 7 about xbox
but
they have no real
idea how the industry works you know
what i'm saying like yeah it's like for
instance this scenario now with with uh
game pass and outriders like instead of
blaming the publisher
that gets all the money
we're going to blame the service that
the publisher put the money on the game
on like makes no sense only people
trying to blame game passes people that
don't understand how the industry works
like
they didn't let they didn't just put
that game on there for free they put it
on there for a lot of money
uh most likely they put that on there
for more money than they would have made
off of selling it on the platform
because microsoft's trying to get was
you got to think that's at that time
when they were trying to really
you know dig deep and show that they had
triple a games and i know someone that
made fun of me saying that i said that
outriders as a triple a product look i
guess technically it's a high-end
double-a
but i mean at the end of the day that is
published by
square enix
so like
like i don't you love how people have
different definitions of what a triple a
double a is that whatever is convenient
for their conversation
yeah it's like look
i get it
you know maybe technically that's not a
triple a title i don't like the word
triple a double a anyway
but it's just like it is what it is man
but you know about
aaa quadruple a oh god what about that
one when we when we go here we're gonna
see that quadruple a perfect dark game
yeah we gonna see that never would have
said that you know that game flops you
know you're going to see videos and
people think i'm saying man the the very
first triple eight uh quadrant it was a
banger
it was a banger that flopped
so you know i definitely uh you know i
appreciate everyone for coming through
uh you know appreciate for gamer forte
coming through where can people find you
out for today
oh man you can find me in the iron lords
chat every sunday at the lord's time of
um 1 p.m until football season starting
to be 11 a.m uh but then you can also
check me out on my channel give me forte
everywhere youtube twitter next month's
live gps podcast will be on my channel
this week if you missed last week's
episode it was on slomo's channel which
was a great show we had um
we had three bit on there amazing guests
a lot of stuff that i didn't know um
about this industry i found out from him
and just that episode alone so please go
to his
go to his channel check it out or
subscribe to us on um any of your
favorite podcast networks and you can
find it over there too uh attic it was a
great show appreciate you and um you
guys have a great week
keep in mind um i am bringing it up the
schedule uh september
the
the fifth is when we start our 11 a.m
dave no the 12th is when we start our
11am debut
so it looks like it's going to be the
12th
so september the 12th all the way
through the majority of the football
season we will be going september the
12th uh also uh keep in mind i'm gonna
start streaming a little bit more so
probably tomorrow uh i will be streaming
probably the the rest of skyward sword i
don't know how close i am to the end i'm
gonna start trying to stream a couple
days a week uh
probably only make two videos a week
because i feel like you know i'm put i
need to to work smarter not harder so i
need to you know separate my content and
i just put all my eggs in one basket uh
definitely follow me on twitter lord
addict iop
we're going to be uh also if you are a
channel member or a patreon of the iron
lords podcast go on those posts and ask
those questions man because we're about
to do that podcast saturday it's
probably going to go up next tuesday or
wednesday and it's going to be you know
we just uh the lords lord cognito lord
sovereign uh king david and myself are
going to be answering questions that you
guys have to ask uh it could be anything
non-gaming related as well doesn't have
to be just gaming
the only thing we really don't want to
talk about it's like politics and
religion and stuff like that because we
we try to be like a safe haven to get
away from a lot of uh the real world
problems we don't really try to talk
about it too too much but definitely go
to those man go go to the patreon if
you're a member we have a post in the
community tab and if you're a patreon
there's a post there ask those questions
because probably here in the next three
days i'm going to be getting all those
questions together i'll probably post
another post tomorrow to remind some
people but definitely go on there uh and
you know until next time this is gamey
addict right here peace